so in parts of the world where rivers
are usually contaminated with sewage
we can find there's one city of 15
million people that uses
its flood plains to treat the water that
is waste water and sewage water that is
coming
out of the city it does this through a
combination of sunshine
sewage and a symbiosis between algae
and bacteria the wastewater which comes
in about 95
water and 5 waste
in this condition is then broken down
and then after that process of breaking
down the water moves into a series of
fish ponds that then clean the water in
a process that takes about 30 days
and on the edges of the city which is
actually the city of
calcutta you can find this incredible
wetland system and this incredible
wastewater aquaculture system
and it's riven by highways and it's
flanked by this smoking escarpment of
all the city's trash called the darpa
you can find
this incredible indigenous technology
and it's composed of these 300
fish ponds that clean the city city's
water
while also producing the city's food
this innovation it's not just
a model for chemical and coal power free
water purification it also provides a
hundred
thousand jobs to the residents of the
city of kolkata
given that calcutta actually has no
other
formal treatment system at its core it's
actually the only way
that the wastewater that coming out of
the core of the city of kolkata can be
cleaned before
it enters the bay of bengal